[Music]
can you draw a narrative threads through
your long and varied artistic career
that's actually a very good question
okay well I think something that I've
been interested in since I was a child
actually is trying to create situations
where much more happened than you
expected to happen so so you have a sort
of input and suddenly things proliferate
from that so for example one of the one
of my favorite games when I was a kid
was to try to make a little railway
engine take the longest possible route
to the bottom of a sort of spiral of
track I would create by resting the
rails on on books and adjusting
carefully and my idea was to get the
longest possible journey from top to
bottom that I could and I would adjust
adjust with playing cards and things
just to slow it down a little bit or
just so it got over that hump so that
that was an idea to sort of what's that
what's the most I can get out of this
simple action of putting a little
railway carriage on top of a spiral of
of downward spiral of rails then as time
went on that started develop into a sort
of an art practice I suppose where I
remember when I was 16 I was in hospital
and somebody brought me in some paints
and some card to paint on and I was
doing sort of abstract expressionist
paintings but but then going through
them through the pictures and cutting
out tiny little pieces like that so out
of one big splashy picture I would get
about a hundred tiny very exquisite
pictures which I sold to the doctors and
nurses actually the first work I ever
sold was in hospital with appendicitis
how much do they paid Oh lots of money
like two and sixpence so so then when I
started making music what interested me
really from the very beginning was
making kind of musical
machines of some kind musical systems
where for quite a small input there
would be a lot of music coming out I
basically want to make infinite music
machines so an example of one of those
that the boat the most simple example
you can imagine is the wind chime you
know a wind chime is a little machine
that you build has maybe five pipes and
the wind activates it and of course it
activates it differently all the time so
there's a there's a constantly changing
infinitely long piece of music from that
so I never made wind chimes but I was
inspired by the idea of making work in
that way so so essentially I think as I
want to make things that that surprised
me that I didn't visualize in advance
you know usually the idea of an artist
is that you have the whole thing in your
head and then somehow you physically
realize that you know so people imagine
that people like Beethoven had
symphonies in their head and then they
carefully wrote it all down and kind of
organized a way for an orchestra to
bring that into life that's never been
an interest for me in fact I don't
believe that it was for Beethoven either
actually I think that's a wrong
impression of how artists work that sort
of idea of the artist as an architect
belongs to architecture architects do
that a realize but I don't think
musicians generally do I think that we
are much more like gardeners with
planting seeds and then how they come up
is different every time you know and
constantly as surprising so I I moved
away from the idea of the artist as
architect meaning as somebody in
possession of a completely clear vision
of the final work I moved away from that
to the artist as gardener
somebody who plants a few seeds and then
watches them grow just as you the
audience watch them grow as one of the
most influential gardeners of the 20th
century do you take stock of your of the
people you've influenced I I don't
really think about it that much to be
honest I mean occasionally I hear
something and I think wow that's really
good at cents just like me
but on the other hand I sometimes hear
think's things and I think wow that's
really good it doesn't sound anything
like me at all so I'm kind of more
interested generally in the things that
aren't like what I do and what what
simple things haven't you yet taken and
made more complicated what's what
continues to motivate you well there
there are two levels of answer to that
question one is a very practical
day-to-day answer which is that there is
constantly new software being invented
which does things that nobody could ever
do before and so it's always been an
interest of mine to see what I could do
with it that nobody had thought of doing
for instance my early use of tape
recorders was really to do with the fact
that the tape recorder turned music from
something ephemeral something that was
in the air to something physical
something on tape so what can you do now
that sound is a physical entity that you
can edit and reverse and stretch and do
things to and so every every new
technology has the possibility of
rethinking the medium that it belongs to
of giving you a new a new way of using
that medium and of expanding the
envelope actually so that's a sort of a
day-to-day interest because there's so
much digital music technology coming out
all the time that if if I'm ever bored I
can just see what's new and try to keep
up with it but the longer term I think
the interest behind all of that is this
fascination I have with how things come
into being and
the classical view of how things come
into being is that very intelligent
things create other things so you know
classically God is at the top and then
he inspires people like Newton and
Darwin and Einstein and Shakespeare and
so on and through them
the brilliance of the deities sort of
spread out to the population and even
people who believe who don't believe in
God still kind of have that model in
their heads I think whereas I being a
Darwinian or a neo-darwinian think that
the most interesting thing about
evolution theory is the possibility that
complexity arises out of simplicity not
the other way around necessarily so so
I'm always interested in trying that
experiment in seeing how how something
incredibly beautiful and unexpected can
be engendered out of simple beginnings
and I think that that's a very very
important social message as well because
our social constructions are still based
on the idea of the pyramid with the
Godhead at the top and all the
intelligence at the top and the sort of
idiots at the bottom making use of what
comes out of it but I just don't think
that's how things come into being so
what don't see then I've been quite
daunted lately because I've been reading
a lot of recent climate science so that
does make you wonder whether any other
question is worth asking and are you
concerned with impact you know you're
clearly conscious of like social issues
do you think what you're doing how
you're applying your creativity now has
the best or most efficient impact
I mean impact is on me is what motivates
me I want to I want to find things out
you know I want to surprise myself or
things so so if if that isn't happening
I don't think I'm doing the right thing
on the other hand now I've become more
and more concerned with this issue of
how long have we got left on this planet
impact does become an issue you know I
suddenly think I suddenly for the first
time in my life want to change people's
minds I want to make people put their
attention somewhere that it may not be
at the moment so then impact does become
an issue and of course the question is
always do you do that best by just
carrying on with what you're good at or
do you say sorry I've got to put that to
one side and do this other thing and
many artists artists have had many
different answers to that on that
spectrum of possibilities you know Metis
spent the whole of the second world war
quietly painting in his studio hoping
that it would pass and then things would
go back to normal and his work would
have a place he was right as it happened
who but he might not be right if he
tried that this time people see yeah
people stopped listening once you
stopped being an artist and starts
trying to be something else yes there's
that that as well yes yeah where does
where does your credibility come from
and I think people have every right to
question your credibility if you
suddenly pop up in an area that you
don't apparently have any credentials
for I mean I think I do have some
credentials because I've been pursuing
this interest for for about 30 or 40
years but I haven't publicly been doing
that
the the question of environment and the
ecology in particular it's sort of the
in a way as the subject matter of my
work again how things come into being
how how systems work cybernetics was one
of the things I studied as a youngster
so so it's a line of thinking that I've
been doing for a for a long while but it
was sort of a private study until
recently for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you